despair in the village of bushushu as
bodies are dragged from the mud 200
people have been killed in flash floods
and landslides in South kivu Province
homes and livelihoods have been swept
away
after the rain we saw the water coming
with pressure and houses started to be
washed away all our houses started to
fall down as a result of the water
people started to scream we saw people
being swept away and we managed to save
ourselves
rescue workers are trying to Free People
trapped under the rubble in their homes
survivors say a permanent solution is
needed for regular flooding during the
rain season
at this time we need to ask our
government to find us a way to move from
here because we don't have any hope to
live here in bushushu where floods often
happen and every time they cost us a lot
of money and a lot of lives
in neighboring Rwanda
130 people were killed in flooding after
heavy rain on Tuesday
and in casese on uganda's border with
Rwanda landslides killed eight people on
Wednesday
back in South kivu people are sleeping
in the open after floods destroyed their
homes their hoping downpours will be
less extreme for the rest of the rain
season which ends in June Barbara and
gopa Al Jazeera